und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend wenn man jetzt am ende des ersten
tages nach halle erste bilanz zieht muss
man eingestehen
es hat wohl tatsächlich die tat dieses
mörders gebraucht damit deutschland
endlich erkennt was da offenbar am
militanten rechtsextremen flügel unserer
gesellschaft brodelt
das ist schlimm acht jahre nach dem mord
zügen des nsu nach immer wiederkehrenden
verfassungsschutzberichten die eine
immer bessere vernetzung und massive
aufrüstung dieser szene beschrieben und
nach dem mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten lücke sollte das
längst klar sein und trotzdem wirken die
offiziellen heute nicht nur entsetzt und
empört sondern auch überrascht
der tag danach in halle beobachtungen
unseres reporters andreas weiß halle
marktplatz am nachmittag immer mehr
kommen um ihre fassungslosigkeit zu
teilen um zu trauern um die beiden opfer
von gestern eine 40 jährige frau und
einen 20-jährigen mann und auch um zu
reflektieren was da geschah
naja man man begreift dass man das dass
die ganze sache tatsächlich relativ nah
an einem dran ist man geschieht manche
dinge immer vor sich weg und nun glaubt
die sachen passieren nicht in seiner
heimatstadt oder bei sich zu hause und
[Musik]
dann wird man auf so eine art und weise
doch wieder auf den boden der tatsachen
geholt
es ist der tag der trauer und der
politischen prominenz in der saalestadt
am mittag kommt der bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier ist die
erschütterung ob der bluttat von halle
anzusehen schweigeminute für die opfer
später tritt das staatsoberhaupt vor die
presse
dieser tag ist ein tag der scham und der
sande dass in diesem unserem land ein
land mit dieser geschichte ein anschlag
auf eine vollbesetzte jüdische synagoge
und das am höchsten jüdischen feiertag
stattfindet
das erfüllt uns alle mit entsetzen und
abscheu auch der bundesinnenminister
kommt nach halle und erinnert daran dass
deutschland aufgrund seiner geschichte
eine besondere verpflichtung im kampf
gegen den antisemitismus
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat einen
schuhe gegenüber der ganzen welt
abgegeben
nie wieder und gerade in solchen stunden
fühlen wir uns diesen schuh tief
verpflichtet
ein großes thema heute in halle die
fehlende polizeipräsenz vor der synagoge
vor allem am höchsten jüdischen feiertag
jom kippur analysen des bka hatten im
vorfeld wohl keine akute bedrohung
gesehen
von der beurteilung von den daraus
folgenden maßnahmen war die polizei das
gitter an dass sie aufgrund der
gefährdungsanalyse tun musste nämlich
eine unregelmäßige bestreitung mit den
juden trauern auch die anderen
glaubensgemeinschaften aiman mazyek vom
zentralrat der muslime spricht mit
angestellten des döner imbiss wo gestern
eines der opfer erschossen wurde
ihr müsst jetzt ihr müsst nicht alleine
sein
alles gut
der junge mann der hier erschossen wurde
war glühender fan des halleschen fc
die freunde des 20 jährigen sind rat-
und fassungslos ich kenne ihn schon
länger und so
dadurch auch fertig mit den nerven die
anderen nur über den täter auch nicht
über die opfer jetzt zu reden
am abend kommen immer mehr menschen zur
synagoge eine stimmung die trauer und
mitgefühl spürbar macht halle versucht
irgendwie das was geschah zu verarbeiten
es wird wohl noch dauern bis das gelingt
es ist ein wesentliches merkmal dieser
hass mörder dass sie der öffentlichkeit
ihr innerstes geradezu aufdrängen
die ermittler bekommen das material für
ein täterprofil im netz geradezu
angeliefert kameraden safari an mit
einem ersten befund karlsruhe heute
nachmittag stephan b wird dem
ermittlungsrichter beim
bundesgerichtshof vorgeführt
der 27 jährige hatte seine tat minuziös
geplant in einem im internet
aufgetauchten manifest schreibt er wir
bewusst den jom kippur gedenkt tag und
die synagoge ausgesucht habe und weiter
tötet alle juden nach unseren
erkenntnissen hat der beschuldigte
stephan b gestern sich zum ziel gesetzt
in der jüdischen gemeinde zu halle in
der synagoge von halle an der saale ein
massaker anzurichten stefan b ein mensch
der wohl tief durchdrungen von einem
erschreckenden antisemitismus
fremdenhass rassismus geprägt war
auch muslime linke und feministinnen
nennt stephan b als potentielle ziele
das manifest zeigt auch fotos der von
ihm verwendeten waffen einige davon soll
er selbst gebaut haben mit teilen aus
einem 3d drucker in bendorf in sachsen
anhalt soll er mit seiner mutter gelebt
haben
sein vater beschreibt ihn als
eigenbrötler er habe in halle chemie
studiert zuletzt arbeitete er als
rundfunktechnik was für ein typ ist er
diese täter versuchen mit der tat ihr
vorher im vorfeld aufgebautes
überbordendes selbstbild ich bin mächtig
ich bin ein weißer mann ich kann die
welt beherrschen dieses auch einem sehr
breiten publikum zugänglich zu machen
wird der moderne terrorismus die der
moderne extremismus lebt von ständiger
vollständiger inszenierung stefan b
hatte vorbilder
auch der attentäter von christchurch
hatte vor seiner tat mit mehr als 50
opfern ein manifest veröffentlicht
stefan b schreibt sein manifest in
englisch und inszeniert seine taten auf
einer streaming plattform im grunde
genommen ist der täter jetzt der
prototyp des modernen extremistischen
attentäters der sich im vorfeld nicht
nur radikalisiert sondern sich gerade
radikalisiert weil er an eine neue
person ist weil er sich selber
inszenieren kann und auch dafür von
einem publikum anerkennung und applaus
bekommt das ist das eigentlich
beunruhigende der täter von halle seinen
weg ab hier würde nicht mehr inszenieren
können
der soziologe mathias quendt beschäftigt
sich mit deutschland rechtsaußen wie
sein kluges aktuelles buch heißt von
politisch ganz national rechts bis zu
den militanten extremen guten abend nach
jena guten abend herr kleber für was
steht so ein theater wie der von halle
die tat von halle und der täter von
halle stehen einerseits für eine
kontinuität von antisemitismus von
rassismus und von rechtsradikaler gewalt
und sie stehen andererseits für eine
modernisierung für eine neue
internationalisierung des rechten
terrors insbesondere über das internet
über die sozialen netzwerke und diese
gemengelage macht die situation auch so
schwierig nun war es ja ein einzeltäter
wie die polizei sagt und duh betont sie
meint damit natürlich nur dass er die
aktuelle tat einzeln begangen hat wie
wichtig ist für die heranbildung so
eines menschen
diese internationale vernetzung der die
so weit führt dass er seine
publikationen auf englisch machen also
zunächst war der täter ja offensichtlich
nicht mal bei der tat alleine sondern er
war über seine helmkamera verbunden mit
mindestens fünf personen die ihm live
bei der tat zugeschaut haben und die
radikalisierung in diesem netzwerk
dieser internationalen der
menschenverachtung die sich in diesen
game channels zusammenschließt und sich
in ihren hass hineinsteigert die ist für
ihn natürlich wichtig gewesen denn da
hat er die ideologie offensichtlich
weiterentwickelt und dass man auch das
milieu des er beeindrucken wollte und
zwar nicht nur beeindrucken mit einem
möglichst hohen mit einer möglichst
hohen opferzahl sondern auch zu
nachahmungstat motivieren wollte so wie
das in seinem manifest geschrieben steht
nun war ja seine brutalität seine
gewaltbereitschaft sehr viel weiter
entwickelt als seine ideologie denn was
er dort zusammen schreibt ist ja einfach
schluss nun das ist nicht nur einfach
schluss es ist die übernahme von
verbreiteten fragmenten in diesen online
subkulturen einerseits in dieser szene
im spiel in die höhe
aber andererseits auch in der anime
kultur da hat er sich also aus der
popkultur verschiedene anleihen genommen
und die verschwörungstheorie der
sogenannten zb derzeit juristische
kopierten regierungen die ist in der
extrem rechten ja weit verbreitet das
war die zentrale verschwörungs legende
im nationalsozialismus dass die juden
die weltherrschaft an sich reißen
wollten das deutsche volk vernichten
wollten
das geht zurück bis auch die protokolle
der weisen von zion die gefälscht sind
dass es vielleicht eine oberflächliche
ideologisierung aber sie ist doch in
sich auf eine schreckliche art und weise
rational im sinne von einer subjektiven
rationalität die antisemiten in
deutschland im grunde schon seit
jahrhunderten kultiviert haben nun
ergeben ja auch ihre untersuchungen dass
die deutsche gesellschaft sich an für
sich in eine ganz andere richtung
entwickelt in der mehrheit offener
liberaler hilfsbereiter wie kann so eine
randgruppe mit solchen blutigen taten
der deutschen gesellschaft gefährlich
werden sie kann der deutschen
gesellschaft dann gefährlich werden wenn
diese nicht adäquat reagiert und das ist
ein problem das wir in deutschland seit
vielen jahrzehnten haben dass die rechte
gewalt der rechte terrorismus nicht
ernst genommen wurden nicht als ein
angriff auch den staat begriffen
denn sie sagen ja richtig dass auch
beispielsweise antisemitische
einstellung im klassischen sinne
zumindest zurückgegangen sind die
zustimmung zu aussagen die die den
holocaust relativieren die
geschichtsrevisionistische sind sind in
der breiten bevölkerung zurückgegangen
aber diese liberalisierung hat zu
rückschlag effekten geführt dass jetzt
nämlich dinge wieder offen und lauter
provokative auch in den parlamenten
gesagt werden von denen wir eigentlich
dachten wir sind weiter die gefahr ist
dass diese rückschläge überdrehen dass
sich also die rassisten die antisemiten
so sehr in die defensive gedrängt fühlen
dass sie der meinung sind es sei legitim
jetzt auch gewalttätige zurückzuschlagen
und dafür auch bestätigung aus
öffentlichen diskursen erfahren können
wird es notwendig sein in deutschland
diesen kampf gegen militanten
rechtsextremismus mit der gleichen härte
und mit denselben großen mitteln zu
führen wie seinerzeit den kampf des
staates gegen die raf terroristen und
ich glaube der staat darf in erster
linie die bürgerrechte nicht verraten
seine freiheitsrechte nicht verraten
nicht überreagieren um die forderungen
der terroristen nach einem autoritären
staat nach im grunde einer diktatur
nicht selber zu erfüllen das bedeutet
über reaktionen des staates können
genauso bedrohlich sein
andererseits ist es natürlich so dass
der rechtsextremismus im kontext im
vergleich auch zu den kampf gegen den
linksextremismus und selbst der
strukturellen aufstellung im umgang mit
dem islamismus bisher vernachlässigt
wurde
das betrifft übrigens nicht nur die
sicherheitsbehörden das betrifft auch
die forschung das betrifft die
öffentlichen diskussion über diese
herausforderungen
das hat sicher was damit zu tun dass
dieser rechtsextremismus eben auch was
mit uns zu tun hat mit unserer
gesellschaft das kommt nicht irgendwo
von außen sondern wir haben es mit einer
radikalisierung von konflikten und mit
von ideologie fragmenten zu tun
die bis weit in die mitte der
gesellschaft hinein reichen müssen die
ideologie fragmente wie sie es nennen
also denkweisen wie der identitäten
bewegungen die sagt also muslime und
araber müssen aus deutschland heraus
gehalten
sonst geht das deutsche volk unter
solche thesen zb in den medien und in
den schulen behandelt werden oder damit
die menschen da nicht unvorbereitet sind
wenn sie dem begegnen
oder verschafft man damit diesen
ideologien als die bühne die sie haben
wollen dann diese ideologien die sind ja
da die werden auch ganz proaktiv vor
allem über das internet aber auch über
politische parteien über die afg über
musik in verschiedenen formen in die
öffentlichkeit getragen deswegen brauche
selbstverständlich eine sensibilisierung
bildung präventionsarbeit die
multiplikatoren die zum beispiel
lehrerinnen und lehrer die aber auch
polizeibeamte in die lage versetzt
überhaupt zu verstehen was sind das für
konzepte was sind das für neue begriffe
die die auftauchen wenn etwa von ethno
pluralismus gesprochen wird was ja
nichts anderes heißt als rassistische
segregation durchzuführen und
einzufordern
da braucht es immer während der
aufklärung denn die rechten und die
radikal rechten passen sich an sie sind
modernisierungs fähig und da darf eine
demokratie wenn sie wehrhaft sein will
nicht hinterher hängen
klingt nach einem großen stück arbeit
dankeschön nach jena gerne weil der
täter seinen plan ins internet gestellt
hat kann jeder sehen wir gescheitert ist
als ihm das klar wurde erschoss er zwei
menschen aus bloßer wut und
menschenverachtung weil sie gerade da
war keine feinde nicht mal in seinem
irrsinnigen weltbild sein feindbild sind
juden in der welt in der sich dieser
täter bewegt ist das selbstverständlich
der geistige sumpf aus dem er kommt ist
erschreckend groß und brodelt die 99,9
prozent die in unserem land nicht juden
sind können ja nur versuchen sich
vorzustellen was das heißt zu menschen
zu gehören die wegen ihrer kultur und
ihren g wegen ihres glaubens gestern
ziel des mordanschlages waren reaktionen
aus der jüdischen gemeinde zum beispiel
in berlin
heute mehr polizei als sonst vor der
synagoge in der oranienburger straße in
berlin mitte
es ist tag eins nach halle
roman -remis war gestern dort in der
synagoge im paulusviertel er hatte
todesangst schlachter bereits während
der mehrzahl kommt jetzt
wir werden abgeschlachtet und das sind
opas gewesen 90 jahre alt die den krieg
überlebt haben waren omas da und und die
gucken wird verständlich was los war und
in dem man dachte ich mir ich
verschwinden also nach nachher und
gebräuche nehme ticket ich fliege nach
israel
wie denken und fühlen deutsche juden
nach dem rechtsextremistischen terror
jüdische gemeinschaft ist schockiert wir
haben bisher gesagt dass die situation
in deutschland noch nicht so schlimm ist
wie in frankreich belgien oder auch in
schweden aber seit gestern ist sie das
wir dürfen uns nicht unterkriegen lassen
und antisemitismus wird vielleicht salon
fähiger und rechtsextremismus wird
radikaler und gefährlicher für die
gesamte gesellschaft das betrifft nicht
nur juden in deutschland sondern das ist
ein angriff auf die gesamte
demokratische wertvorstellung die wir in
deutschland gott sei dank leben
sie sind deutsche jüdischen glaubens und
wollen bleiben in ihrer heimat verdi
verlässt so sagen sie erfüllt die ziele
der antisemiten
sie feiern heute trotzdem jüdisches
leben in deutschland seit zehn jahren
gibt es das studentenwerk elis dass
begabte juden fördert wir sind alle mit
der fragilität auch jüdischen lebens
aufgewachsen
fast alle installierten institutionen
sind immer bewacht worden
es war für mich als kleines kind schon
normal dass mein vater keine keeper auf
der straße getragen hat und aus gutem
grund ich glaube wer heute überrascht
ist verkennt die lange geschichte die
kontinuität von rechts terrorismus in
deutschland
doch natürlich werden die
feierlichkeiten vom hass von halle
überlagert
ich bin es leid des rechtsextremismus
offen das wort geredet wird und diese
borniertheit klammheimliche zustimmung
findet in unserem land ich sage es
deutlich wer dafür auch nur einen funken
verständnis aufbringt der macht sich
mitschuldig für taten weh gestern blumen
für die opfer zeichen der anteilnahme
ist das genug
was wir brauchen ist ein tägliches
zeichen der solidarität indem
beispielsweise menschen einen davidstern
tragen und im idealfall sollten es so
viele sein dass juden wieder ermutigt
werden selbst david stern zu fragen
antisemiten werden dadurch entmutigt
weil sie sehen es sind so viele die die
jüdische gemeinde unterstützen der kampf
gegen das judentum hat eigentlich gar
keinen sinn mehr solidarität ist nötig
doch wie viel kann und will die
gesellschaft zeigen
das wird sich weisen
der täter wollte aktiver teil der
globalen rechts militanten internetszene
seien dafür kommende kommunizierte er
auf englisch
ein hintergrund über solche plattformen
finden sie auf heute.de damit zu der
militäraktion die heute die welt und den
weltsicherheitsrat beschäftigte der
türkische einmarsch in nordsyrien
schutzzone in den präsident erdogan das
gebiet das er unter seine kontrolle
bringen will und dafür lässt er es
bombardieren auch bodentruppen sind seit
gestern abend im einsatz
die kurden die dort vertrieben werden
sollen schießen zurück mit dem was sie
haben
die explosionen waren den ganzen tag
über zu hören entlang der türkisch
syrischen grenze
man habe bislang alle vorgesehenen
zielgebiete eingenommen so der türkische
generalstab mehr als 170 terroristen
seien schon ausgeschaltet
gemeint sind kämpfer wie diese hier die
bis letzte woche noch mit den usa
verbündeten kurdischen milizen in
nordsyrien der hochgerüsteten nato armee
haben sie nicht viel entgegenzusetzen
ihre heimat wollen sie trotzdem mit
aller kraft verteidigen in der von
erdogan geplanten sogenannten schutz
ohne so ihrer furcht wird für kunden
kaum noch platz sein denn zusammen mit
der türkischen armee kommen seit gestern
hunderte arabisch syrische freischärler
über die grenze vorhut für die geplante
neuansiedlung von syrischen flüchtlingen
aus der türkei in den kurdengebieten
verzweifelt wandte sich eine kurdische
politikerin aus syrien heute in brüssel
an die europäische öffentlichkeit
dieser angriff muss sofort gestoppt der
syrische luftraum für türkische
flugzeuge gesperrt werden doch daraus
wird wohl nichts zwar verurteilten
berlin und paris das türkische vorgehen
doch der starke mann in ankara kann
darüber nur müde lächeln er erinnerte
die europäer heute noch einmal daran wie
sehr sie ihm ausgeliefert sind
wenn ihr versucht unsere operation als
invasion darzustellen werden wir die
türen öffnen und 3,6 millionen
flüchtlinge zu schicken
die militär operation forderte heute
auch auf türkischer seite sechs tote und
mehrere verletzte
als granaten von kurdischen kämpfern
über die grenze hinweg auf mehrere
türkische orte abgefeuert wurden einige
kilometer weiter südlich fliehen seit
gestern 60.000 bewohner aus orten
entlang der grenze ins syrische
landesinnere
auf der suche nach schutz vor den
türkischen bomben es waren sechs oder
sieben einschläge alle wollen jetzt weg
aber es gibt nicht genug autos eine
spiegel reporterin war zu beginn der
offensive gestern in der grenzstadt
russell ein ziel getroffen wurden und
spätestens dann macht es doch die
letzten flüchten auf den weg die straßen
waren gesäumt von menschen die zu fuß
versucht haben was die stadt heraus zu
kommen nur weg von der grenze bislang
wurden nach syrischen angaben mindestens
30 menschen getötet und über 100
verletzt
die türkische armee setzte am abend
ihren beschuss fort die nachrichten
dieses tages von gundula gause
die linksfraktion im bundestag hat vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht gegen die
beteiligung der bundeswehr an der
internationalen anti es mission geklagt
und ist damit gescheitert
die richter wiesen den antrag als
unzulässig ab zugleich machten sie
deutlich dass sie den ausbildungs
einsatz der etwa 450 deutschen soldaten
im irak und in syrien grundsätzlich
rechtlich begründet sehen obwohl es kein
un mandat dafür gibt großbritanniens
premier johnson und der irische
ministerpräsident wodka haben über den
brics it beraten und sich danach positiv
geäußert ein abkommen sei im interesse
aller verkündeten beide nach einem
zweistündigen gespräch ohne details
preiszugeben
es sei auch um die herausforderungen des
zolls gegangen
viele fragen seien aber noch zu klären
in ecuador dauern die proteste gegen die
sparmaßnahmen der regierung an
diese hat inzwischen den ausnahmezustand
verhängt nachdem es eine woche lang
immer wieder zu schweren ausschreitungen
gekommen war
auslöser war die streichung von
treibstoff subventionen um einen
hilfskredit des internationalen
währungsfonds zu bekommen
daraufhin hatten sich die spritpreise
verdoppelt in rumänien ist die
sozialdemokratische regierung von
ministerpräsidentin dann schüler durch
ein misstrauensvotum gestürzt worden
die opposition hatte den antrag gestellt
sie wirft ein schüler inkompetenz und
mangelnde investitionsbereitschaft vor
das europaparlament hat die französische
kandidatin für die neue eu kommission
abgelehnt
die frühere verteidigungsministerin
frankreichs solar erhielt im zuständigen
ausschuss nicht die erforderliche
mehrheit
hintergrund sind ermittlungen zu einer
schein beschäftigungs affäre makro
machte die designierte eu
kommissionspräsident in von
allein für das scheitern verantwortlich
sie habe sich für gute entschieden
obwohl er von der leyen auf die
laufenden ermittlungen hingewiesen habe
als erfolg für präsident makro wird
dagegen eine verständigung der
eu-finanzminister gesehen sie haben nach
langer debatte einen eigenen haushalt
für die eurozone beschlossen
zwar viel kleiner als von makro
gefordert aber frank bethmann immerhin
wozu genau dient dieser neue gelte das
geld aus dem topf soll vor allem dafür
sorgen dass sich die wirtschaftlichen
verhältnisse angleichen dass es zwischen
den euro mitgliedstaaten künftig nicht
mehr so große unterschiede gibt wie
bisher den finanzministern war aber
wichtig zu betonen dass es trotzdem kein
reiner umverteilung stop sein soll
sondern dass alle länder auch die
reicheren wie deutschland mindestens 70
prozent als finanzierungsmittel zurück
bekommen sollen
im einzelnen verständigte man sich auf
ein budget von 17 milliarden euro für
sieben jahre
geld gibt es nur gegen vorlage von
reformen und investitionsplänen und
jeder staat muss 25 prozent an eigenem
geld mitbringen um auszahlungen aus dem
budget topf zu erhalten
17 milliarden euro über sieben jahre
sind natürlich nicht der große wurf es
ist nur ein bruchteil des gesamten eu
budgets von weit über einer billion euro
für den gleichen zeitraum aber 17
milliarden sind ein anfang beute zu
hören und die summe könne jederzeit
erhöht werden mit der kleinen
einschränkung so denn alle 19 euro
finanzminister auch dieser meinung sind
vielen dank frank der wegen mordes an
der 15-jährigen mia im rheinland
pfälzischen kandel verurteilte abdul d
ist tot in seiner gefängniszelle
aufgefunden worden
ersten erkenntnissen zufolge hat sich
der vermutlich aus afghanistan stammende
mann der jugendstrafanstalt
schifferstadt erhält ende dezember 2017
hatte er seine ex freundin in einem
drogeriemarkt in kandel mit einem messer
tödlich verletzt
deutsche und österreicher haben ja beide
die neigung das gute bei den anderen für
sich
in anspruch zu nehmen deshalb dürften
sich deutsche über den literatur
nobelpreis für peter handke mit freuen
es gab einen zweiten eigentlich ist es
der erste für die fast eine generation
jüngere schriftstellerin olga tokarczuk
aus polen bei ihr ist es der nachgeholte
preis für das letzte jahr
damals hatte sich die novelle jury in
einem strudel langem schwelender
skandale um sex geld und verrat sowas
von unmöglich gemacht dass sie nichts
mehr zu sagen hatte
das soll nun ausgestanden sein die
entscheidung einer neu verfassten jury
heute ein neuanfang werden
claudio armbruster stellt die laureaten
vor olga tokarczuk heute in bielefeld
auf dem weg zu einer lesung von der
pressemeute empfangen und vom donner
gerührt ich finde immer noch überrascht
es ist verrückt der seltsamste ort den
nobelpreis anrufe zu bekommen auf der
autobahn zwischen berlin und bielefeld
olga tokarczuk 57 jahre alt eine der
erfolgreichsten autorinnen polens unrast
heißt einer ihrer bekanntesten romane
geehrt wird sie jetzt für ihre
erzählweise und erzählfreude poetisch
politisch mythisch märchenhaft ich weiß
dass ich eine gute schriftstellerin bin
aber damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet
und er peter handke preisträger 2009 10
der 76 jährige heute vor seinem haus in
frankreich regus ist
ich war erstaunt ja sie haben ein werk
ausgezeichnet nicht mich ich bin keine
gewinne natur
kennst du nach haus mit ihrer
betroffenheit stecken sie sich den arsch
seine natur ist er zornig rebellisch
arschloch damit wurde er berühmt mit
seiner publikumsbeschimpfung 1966
laufend weil halter ihr vaterlandslose
gesellen die revoluzzer rückständiger im
verschmutzer des eigenen netzes von
anfang an hat handke die leser und
kritiker polarisiert für die einen ein
literarischer messias für die anderen
ein hochstapler mit schlechten manieren
gerne provokant selten langweilig die
angst des tormanns beim elfmeter
jahrelang schullektüre und verfilmt von
dem benders verwenders schrieb handke
auch das drehbuch zu der himmel über
berlin
es ist herrlich nur geistig zu leben und
tag für tag für die ewigkeit von den
leuten rein was geistliches zu bezeugen
kannte der streitbare in den 90er jahren
bezieht einen jugoslawienkrieg position
für die serbische seite und verteidigt
den kriegsverbrecher milosevic handke
gerät in die kritik
die debatte wird nach bis heute es gab
viel aufregung damals und die kann ich
auch verstehen
und deswegen ist es auch eine besonders
mutige entscheidung der akademie in
stockholm
die akademie in stockholm 2014 noch
schimpfte er man solle den
literatur-nobelpreis endlich abschaffen
er bringe der literaturen nicht viel
gutes
nun hat er den preis die akademie rüben
tantris sprachliche genialität und sagt
am telefon sei er sehr sehr gerührt
gewesen immerhin dann können sie ein
preuße jetzt abschafft der schwerpunkt
des tages und unsere sendung die
terrortat von halle ist auch das thema
bei maybrit illner gleich wir sagen
[Musik]
guten abend schön dass sie mit dabei
sind wir starten heute direkt mal mit
einem blick auf die sonnenschein
ausbeute des wochenendes und da sehen
wir direkt der süden ist klar im vorteil
am freitag und am samstag bis zu 10
stunden sonne
am samstag ist es auch in der mitte
freundlich mit um die sieben stunden
sonne aber an beiden tagen schaut doch
der norden mit 0 stunden sonne ein
bisschen in die röhre
erst am sonntag lässt sich die sonne
zwischendurch auch im norden mal blicken
also der goldene oktober schlägt vor
allem im süden voll durch warum
tja dann liegt dieses hoch hier nicht
mehr südwestlich von uns sondern eben
südöstlich und dadurch wird der weg frei
für sehr warme luft aus dem südwesten
und so lassen die schauer schon heute
nach dem süden nach teils klart es auf
dann null grad an den alpen es bildet
sich aber auch nebel wohingegen in den
norden noch mal dichtere wolken mit
regen ziehen bei 8 bis 12 grad
und so könnte auch der morgige tag nicht
unterschiedlicher sein
nördlich einer linie niederrhein
nordbrandenburg es ist regnerisch teils
stürmisch vor allem an der see
daran schließt sich ein bewölkter aber
trockener streifen bis zum main an und
südlich des mains da spürt man kaum wind
und es strahlt die sonne und das sieht
dann insgesamt so aus bis zu 20 mm regen
morgen im norden dafür bis zu zehn
stunden sonne im süden
ja und die temperaturen 14 grad an den
küsten und 22 grad am oberrhein und
diese schafe zweiteilung bleibt uns auch
noch am samstag wie gesagt erst am
sonntag und am montag weicht die auf
dann gibt s t shirt wärme von 25 26 grad